I also want to say a word about the
decision yesterday made by the Florida
Board of Education to expand the state's
dystopian don't say gay law teachers in
Florida have already faced the
devastating consequences under threat of
having their licenses revoked gay
teachers have been forced to take down
pictures of their spouses from their
desks conservative politicians love to
complain about the so-called cancel
culture
all while threatening teachers with
losing their jobs if they teach
something that the Maga extremists don't
agree with this idea that a teacher can
have a picture of their spouse or
boyfriend or girlfriend on their desk
completely not true actually Community
notes which is Twitter's new
crowd-sourced uh fact-checking system
they completely blew her apart on this
there is no assault on lgbtqi people
here in Florida please show me what
teachers have been fired for doing any
of these things it is simply not true